welcome to this video playing a lamppost
from France
okay well let's let's play Queens gambit
declined just very classical stuff maybe
the Tartar Cova karthik kovai McAuliffe
under a scheme tmb with bishop age form
III b6 and the western hemispheres
usually is just the tattoo cover but
then in Eastern Europe from a Soviet
Union it's usually called toddler Kohaku
gone up on the rescue mm-hmm
okay see d5 is the the oldest line
against this after which 95 is the best
smooth and yeah this is in fact well
known from the days of the Fischer
Spassky match in game 6
Fischer for the Spassky M we had exactly
this line fish however didn't play
Bishop e2 he played Bishop to b5 in a
similar situation and I think he played
Queen a4 actually and then Bishop I'm
not I'm not 100% sure okay what we have
here is the the typical hanging pawns
formation and I'm going to build up with
Queen B 797 at a 5 this is one of the
ways to to set up the pieces
yeah Queen here maybe wants to go Queen
a3
interesting if a no-go queen b7 queen a
397 des Bishop e6 opening an exchange so
funny funny possible at him okay let's
start with this okay so now maybe queen
b7 intending 97 and also putting some
pressure on the b-pawn it's not likely
that it will be attacked soon but still
aha interesting yeah 97 he might just
take but okay I need to get the bishop
out I had a night out this hanging
pornea is not not so so much of a
problem I have various ways to play this
Bishop g4 or just Bishop e6 if it takes
I'll take b2 at the end this is not so
bad
the other possibility is actually to
cover here with the Queen and after rook
takes the play Bishop to e6 hmm
twin befalls also move and there is also
I know it looks maybe a bit strange
there's a new c4
yeah come on it looks weird because it
gives up deform but the positive side is
it keeps pressure on B - this is for
instance after night after queen before
some quite comfortable I think rook b8
coming attacking Balu okay should I just
pile up on the be Farouk v6 rupee aid
maybe
there are some famous games in this pawn
structure with d5 and C for advanced
giving up the D for scam a very famous
game of Kappa Blancas where he won
exactly the structure okay there should
be six I guess next rook b8 oh yeah it's
over appeared this is some serious
counter play against the pawn can play
Knight f4 maybe oh this I really didn't
think of it all
interesting maybe Queen to f6 and we are
possibly Bishop f5 Bishop f5 and also
would be nice
attacking e3
I don't have so much time so I need to
just play this and hope that the counter
play against b2 is enough I haven't
really looked at f5 which is maybe a
problem no okay so I can't play a
five-year securing this I know a lot of
people would think that white is much
better here that's not the case it's
really not maybe four of us miss
something concrete like here if there
may be the root end game is a bit bit
too problematic 90s but should be two
days but okay okay I have serious play
with the C pawn
it's not so easy for what to make any
progress maybe be three but okay I can
with the King away probably
efore was probably not a good idea
draw Harvard he offers a draw
interesting I don't know I feel I'm okay
here
check I can take rook takes you for now
check ah what the how long yeah they
came I can always take the draw it I
thought I can I can do maybe something
ready
check check check check
I can I can just get the kingside check
I believe white forfeits one time it was
it was very bit of a fishy decision to
continue but I know there are people who
think that this is just bad for black
but I'm not I'm not sold William because
of the the pressure against the b-pawn
it looks ugly but White has no no direct
way forward it's a maybe you find
something concrete like a blundered
something but in general the structure
is okay the computers is unequal so it
for once approves
efore is probably questionable here I
wanted to regroup the bishop to see six
so that it covers d5 and a form but now
I'm around here I made a mistake when I
went have blundered yeah this is not
simply not great I can play a normal
move Bishop c6 or something and it's
probably really very dry I mean the the
SEC is not not totally idiotic but I
have just the complete problem that this
is working and this means I probably
have to go here yeah this is this is
maybe even playable if I look at if I
look at this get the bishop over here
and then get the sorry get the before
Tom it's maybe not so bad
Jack and yeah well here funny the
computer gives it as equal yeah that's
crazy yeah okay the pawn is dangerous I
wish up d3 okay but I had to add they
didn't have much time it should be three
wins the exchange I went to the rook
Jack yeah I was just glad to have the a
plan had pushed it and she ran I can't
do that I don't think I'm risking so
much
oh here okay three is strong check check
yeah I know I'm better again because I
get the Kings side it was really and it
wasn't a time play I was really trying
to win this on on position that he had
he had rook a3 which I didn't see him
jack I only have a couple of seconds and
now the problem is I need to go back and
I cannot go forward then white is better
I can can use the King to defend against
the pawn yeah complicated stuff thanks
for watching